a
[Música]
ah
así es méxico sigue levantando la voz
ante organismos sobre todo de los eeuu
por considerar violatoria esta medida
que ha tomado de estas deportaciones
masivas por aire desde la semana pasada
y es que están regresando sobre todo a
nuestro país miles de personas de
distintas nacionalidades principalmente
centroamericanos de honduras de
guatemala del salvador también de haití
pero sobre todo también de méxico y es
que no solamente en nuestro país se suma
este reclamo organismos internacionales
como la onu unicef e incluso también la
organización internacional de las
migraciones lavín considera como
violatorias estas medidas entonces son
las que están siendo regresadas
inmediatamente sin tener la posibilidad
de este asilo y bueno en medio de esto
en nuestro país sigue recibiendo muchas
solicitudes de asilo de estas personas
que ven prácticamente imposible cruzar
hacia los estados unidos la cifra ya va
en cerca de 65 mil una cifra que podría
crecer según los expertos a los 80 mil
antes de que termine el año
[Música]
turquía y lleva meses denunciando la
supuesta devolución en caliente por
parte de grecia de miles de refugiados a
las costas turcas una práctica ilegal
según el asilo europeo que pone en
riesgo la vida de miles de personas
según datos del gobierno turco en lo que
va de año grecia habría empujado al mar
más de cinco mil personas y cientos de
migrantes denuncian a varias ongs que
grecia siempre sigue la misma práctica
primero requisa las pertenencias de
estos migrantes y luego los empuja a
aguas turcas incluso en algunas
ocasiones ha llegado a pinchar la barca
en la que viajaban amnistía
internacional y las autoridades europeas
han denunciado esta practicada por parte
de grecia e incluso han criticado y
acusado a grecia de torturas por su
parte las autoridades helenas niegan
esta práctica y piden ayuda a los países
vecinos para gestionar la llegada de
inmigrantes a sus costas
[Música]
la crisis de los migrantes y lituania
parece estar todavía muy lejos de poder
solucionarse en lo que va de año más de
4000 personas la mayoría provenientes de
irak han intentado colocar desde
bielorrusia hasta lituania algo que ha
causado una crisis social sin
precedentes en este pequeño país báltico
que el año pasado por ejemplo solo
registró 20 intentos de ilegales
cruzando su frontera tanto es así que
tanto el gobierno lee su mano como la
propia unión europea han acusado al
presidente alexander lukashenko el
presidente bielorruso de estar generando
este flujo migratorio como venganza
contra la unión europea y especialmente
contra los países bálticos por haber
apoyado a la oposición bielorrusa esta
situación está generando un caos social
en la zona muy peligroso ya que en
muchos casos los lituanos devuelven en
caliente a estos migrantes que a su vez
se encuentran al ejército bielorruso al
otro lado que les espera armados hasta
los dientes creando así un espacio para
la tensión social muy peligroso
recordemos que lituania es un país
báltico muy muy pequeño de hecho
lituania ya está empezando a levantar
todo tipo de bayas todo tipo de defensas
alrededor de la frontera con bielorrusia
y se plantea incluso levantar un muro a
lo largo y ancho de esta frontera con
bielorrusia algo inédito en este pequeño
país báltico
[Música]